Bill: Well, first went the record stores
then crowds thinned down at the library
and now you have to wonder
if physical classrooms
could become another
casualty of the Internet age.
Well if Khan Academy is
any indication, the old
schoolhouse will survive
but the way kids spend
their time inside it could change forever.
So why are millions logging on
to get lessons from one man?
Could your kids benefit?
My co-anchor, Terry
Moran went to find out.
(school bell rings)
Terry: No matter how old you are,
you can probably still
remember what the bell
sounded like at your school.
You can still remember
pushing your way through the
hallways to your next
class or the minute hand on
the clock in your math
class that you swore ran
slower than every other clock in
the building, but that was then.
This is now.
Khan: 8 meters and the
same thing along the side.
Terry: Welcome to the Khan
Academy, online learning
on steroids, a one world
schoolhouse that is
skyrocketing in popularity,
sparking controversy and
fundamentally challenging the very notion
of education in the 21st century.
Khan: What we're talking right
now is the learning side.
How can we democratize
the information, the
knowledge, so that anyone
can get to whatever level
they want to.
Terry: Sal Khan founded
the Khan Academy kind of
by accident, more on that in a minute.
First, the sheer scale of this thing.
Seven million students
around the world are
attending the Khan
Academy online every month
and that number is
growing by 400% per year.
The thousands of lessons,
everything from Algebra
to Medieval History to the
Fiscal Cliff, they've been
viewed more than 200 million
times and all for free.
Terry: Are you out to dismantle
our educational system?
Khan: I'm not an education radical.
A lot of what I'm doing
and we're doing is really
bringing back very, very
old ideas that have been
proven, but somehow got lost in the fray?
Terry: Sal Khan is an
unlikely education reformer.
He's a former hedge fund
analyst, MIT undergrad,
Harvard MBA, who just really stumbled
upon his revolution when
he tried to help a young
cousin with her algebra
homework back in 2004.
Khan: I started tutoring her
remotely. I was in Boston,
she was in New Orleans
and after that I started
tutoring other family
members and eventually
put the stuff on YouTube.
Terry: In a few weeks, Khan
noticed that the "stuff"
that he was making for his
relatives was going viral.
The requests from strangers
for more, more, more.
Khan: Antibiotics.
Terry: Visually, they aren't
the kind of videos you'd
expect to go viral. They're
more of a virtual blackboard,
but they work and education
reformers all over the
world have noticed,
including some heavy hitters.
Bill: There's a new website
that I've just been using,
with my kids recently called
Khan Academy, K-H-A-N,
just one guy doing some
unbelievable 15-minute tutorials.
Terry: Bill Gates did
more than look at the Khan
Academy videos. He helped
to bankroll the project.
So in 2009, Khan finally
quit his day job and
partnered with the Gates
Foundation and Google to
form the Khan Academy.
Here's how it works.
Students watch the
videos and then work on a
problem set based on the
lesson on the website.
If you pass, you move
onto the next lesson.
If it looks like you don't
understand a concept,
the site takes you back
through what you are missing.
The goal is not to replace
the traditional classroom.
The goal is to liberate.
Khan: The idea of
students being grouped in
age base co-horts and
then going at a set pace,
this is the school that
we all kind of grew up in,
this is actually not the
way students were educated
for most of history.
Terry: Instead, Khan and
his allies see classrooms
thrumming with creative activity,
spurred by the fact that
kids will have already
engaged the subject matter
through the online lessons.
What does your ideal classroom look like?
Khan: It won't be a bunch
of chairs all positioned
looking at someone in the
front of the classroom.
It'll be a much more collaborative space.
It's not one pace fits all
anymore and the teacher
will be doing focus
interventions with them.
They'll be mentoring them.
They'll be inspiring them.
They won't be lecturing at them.
Terry: About 25-30
schools, most of them based
around Silicon Valley
have started implementing
the Khan Academy as a pilot
program, exploring how
it might change teaching and learning.
There are plenty of critics,
but one big group of supporters.
Khan: The single biggest
thing that happened and
it wasn't obvious to us at
first, the teachers and the
principal told us, is that
the students started to take
ownership of their learning.
They started to not
say, "Hey, I'm passive."
"Tell me what to do next."
They started to say, "These are my goals."
"I'm going to seek out the information."
"Teacher, you're my coach.
You're my mentor. Help me do it."
Terry: They're already
online, maybe at least in some
ways that's where their
classrooms can be, too.
Bill: And Khan's book,
The One World Schoolhouse,
is in stores now. Thanks to Terry.